there's that side of it and you don't
want to ever sound like you're complaint
no I just you know but like and then
once I'm a mom and I went back to work
when she was three years old and I was
on like a two-hander and in every scene
and I'm like oh my God
how can I do this because you are
sometimes 16 18 hour days you know
there's a lot of other things that go
into it which it's harder on your
personal life and if you have a kid
um and I always joke I'm like oh you
know I always dated co-stars because
you're not going to see anybody else
and then we're like all right how many
co-stars do you think you've dated in
your life well I don't know would you
say A3 B7 C more than seven I would say
d all of them no I'm just kidding
um I have had two public relationships
that were co-stars right everybody knows
that do they
well one you had a kid with oh yeah I
guess that gives that one away jumper
which is a great movie oh thanks that
was so much oh it's great you love
jumper I never saw it what you're a [__]
this is the last God why would you say
Star Wars though I wasn't in store yeah
I don't know
have you ever had situations where
you're dating your co-star and it's just
not going well on set now it's just a
weird vibe and you're like [__] I don't
you know I obviously Adam Brody and I
dated on the OC and we broke up like
right before the end of the show oh
perfect yeah you know the timing was
everything and we had to do the last I
want to say a couple months Maybe
but we got along really well
um and I would say it was the best maybe
it wasn't even a couple months maybe it
was a couple weeks but it was like the
best version of it because I'm sure it
could go
South yes yeah I'm sure I hear that
um
yeah it's just I I've never I I did that
in Germany once I was doing this movie
that no one will ever see
um don't ask me I was gonna say what is
it it doesn't matter don't you even I
know you know what it is yeah no no it's
it's it don't even get what is it Ryan
Rave Macbeth okay it was a movie that
looked it was it should have been good
but then we had to dub the entire movie
oh no they lost the audio and now it's
just a joke they lost to the audience
yeah it was all gone I had the loop I
was the lead I had to do every line and
it ruined I was in there going because I
had an obligation I was like I don't
want to [__] be here I just I can't
believe I'm doing every line my
performance I'm emotional and screaming
and drug induced and like I'm going oh
[__] you oh my God that's brutal but
anyway I I was right away I we were my
co-star and I were really attracted to
uh each other her name was Nikki Aycock
she passed just passed away what yeah
she just passed away it shocked me I
believe it was leukemia oh my God I
hadn't been in touch with her for years
but I I adored her she was so sweet we
got along so well and you know what we
it happened and then we kind of were
like you know I'm like hey I'm my 20s
and I'm like you know you know and you
know we started but it ended up working
okay but it could have been a disaster
it could have been a disaster but we
were both cool about it that's good yeah
so I just hope they're cool people yeah
it's uh I mean do you have sort of a a
propensity for going out with actors
um what does that mean uh you know just
like is this do you does it have to be
an actor or a producer or someone in the
business no it doesn't
no
of course not there is the thing that
like they understand like what exactly
you do yeah you know and they get it but
and look yes my track record there you
know I have dated actors
um you know what's funny I haven't you
haven't I don't know I haven't ever I
mean yeah no that's not true I have
forget it I have I just thought about it
I was like yeah you do no yeah